live from the Jon Lovitz comedy club at
city wok Universal Studio Hollywood its
Hollywood babble-on
it is Saturday night in Hollywood so
let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman hey welcome back sir
Thank You miles on the road I miss [ __ ]
and I really miss [ __ ] because I opened
up my Twitter account people like [ __ ]
off Lovitz rules no they don't
good night class though it is do you get
to get a word in edgewise I'm not often
no the only thing I get to say is stop
taking the piss out of me would you love
it he beats me up well we have a good
time a gentle lover yeah I kiss your
neck and [ __ ] like that the good stuff
he just jams it in no little mo dry on
the bone and [ __ ]
that's the ticket that's the bigot but
we're gonna have you back against the
ground for a while I am am I gonna wear
up a little bit we start sir SModcast
internet radio on Monday morning I'm
gonna be here I'm gonna be home I'm not
leaving my house due to put a radio
station in there I bought a bunch of
provisions I ain't going nowhere you're
going like you're in a bunker yeah well
we're glad you're here tonight thanks
for coming out everybody we certainly
appreciate it
we had a standing O another notice
you're not yeah standing oh when we came
out here this gentleman here one a one
man standing on a bridge near the yeah
so it's not really a standing O as much
as standing alone well II just adjusting
his pants I think actually is what he
was doing
he's raised as it was I was adjusting my
dick but I do respect your work that's
good news we gave him a semi alright but
we do appreciate your folks coming out
so we start off every show by giving
shoutouts to folks who came particularly
long distances or celebrating special
occasions I want to start off with
Carlos Rangel Carlos there you are my
brother don't jump dude he's coming over
the rail well maybe he should jump
because I read here that this is his
bachelor party yeah it's all over
captain at least he's got 3 of his
closest friends to [ __ ] tonight yeah
that one dude is just like here's my
chance put all this time I've wanted
that dick be first
no he just knows he doesn't want to go
last he's the least excited about it he
just wants not the end up with sloppy
fourths Oh take forth because if y'all
tuckered by alright that point II might
just be like jerk me off a little Mike
okay I'll fly I'm writing here to let
you know that me and my buddies will be
spending part of my last night out as a
bachelor celebrating with you guys at
tonight's show Carlos writes really this
is the bachelor party
that's a [ __ ] lame bachelor party
only man I'll pick up my tits and suck
them if you want yeah
get your singles out Kevin to stage one
Kevin to stage one everybody I did your
signals up for money I'd do it for a
while okay as loyal members of the GAR
me me and the guys would appreciate it
if you could give me a right proper
send-off by asking the lovely ladies of
the club as Sean Connery for a twenty
two boob salute I don't think hey the
lady's gonna be whipping them out for
you tonight fellas
oh hell Kevin we'll all right I'll ask
though Sean we'll ask for you I'm
disgusted that you would ask women to
raise their shirts and show you their
boobs does anyone knows you just rip
their [ __ ] shirts off if you want to
see their kids and if they complain you
rip their pitch off pictures gotten
grumpy in his old age Ralph and Kevin my
name is Moe shawnette as Moe here
tonight where's mom hey moe so aside do
something special with my friends from
Seattle you came all the way from
Seattle Wow what is most and Fort Morgan
so it's mo Shauna
right on and a name like that you either
better cure cancer become a stripper man
that name says something you know or an
NBA player mo Sean it yeah just never be
less Sean it
by the time you read this email we will
have driven roughly 20 hours to see the
show you're gonna nod off halfway
through oh I get a kick out of it if
Ralph would leave but read the lyrics to
psycho killer by the Talking Heads as
Sean Connery well Sean's got a lot of
work tonight to think this is esoteric I
like that but he included the lyrics so
here we go okay I can't seem to face up
to facts I'm tense and nervous and I
can't relax I can't sleep because my
beds on fire don't touch me i'ma leave a
real live wire psycho killer run run run
run away we had 20 hours on the road to
come up with some vacation but the go
goes no no that's not it Ralph
could you please give a shout-out to me
and my son this is Jodi and Isaac right
in this guy's here from missing Michigan
hey or schmick chigan as he says hey
yeah could you give my wife back home a
Mother's Day greeting in the voice of
Harrison Ford she would appreciate it
what because you left her home on a
Mother's Day happy Mother's Day hardly
seems like satisfaction but I'm sure the
Michigan fronted the garment is strong
thanks for the funnies Jodi and Isaac
thank you guys for coming out this is to
your wife back in Mason Michigan
you did a great job reading my stomach
[Music]
[Music]
there you go that's from Paul chance
Paul chance in the audience Paul hey
Paul how are you for his 40th birthday
his wife Lisa got tickets to the show
and a hotel room at the universal Hilton
oh yeah time for a Hollywood threesome
you're always trying to include yourself
hey you don't have to touch me I just
want to watch he says this is literally
the very first time in over ten years
we've been away from our kids overnight
so this is a big deal for us you know
[Applause]
where's Lisa where's your wife Lisa yeah
she's the one shaking her head no I met
you're gonna pork him hit him hard I'd
be eternally grateful if you tell these
how beautiful and awesome she is in
Edwin's voice this will do it yes tell
keV I actually like to Jersey girl oh
the suits a genius sorry I can't do that
oh my goodness Lisa look at you you've
never looked more lovely in your hoody
about 18 pina coladas been oh my
goodness you look truck enough like
you're up for anything don't you no time
to get that sphincter yodeling ee oh my
goodness you won't be walking straight
for a week once all's done with you
that's a help don't you know I've been
there run the black light over the
spread before you lay down say shan't
take off your pants tonight you'll be
saying shan't take off your pal Rene's
here from London via Melbourne Australia
where's Rene [ __ ] you Rene you're not
here what well make some noise Renee
Renee Renee sent us some photos she and
her boyfriend Chris were at the Prince
Charles cinema in London recently and
they went into your stall right on man
well Chris did they sent us some photos
of all the pictures and stuff that are
hanging in the Kevin Smith stall we're
not gonna look at them no because Chris
decided to include his [ __ ] in one of
the pictures
it's him standing over the toilet with
his [ __ ] out and I realized I didn't
really want to see that I don't know
we've seen like a lot of had Lois you
seen Asia's ass yeah I don't see Chris's
[ __ ] until it's in a movie all right
yeah he may be in a movie with his [ __ ]
out I don't know but thanks for coming
all that way Rene we appreciate it
thanks for taking your dick out I
respect that Nate and Tim you guys here
tonight from Texas these guys drove all
the way from Texas straight from Texas
24 hours from Texas here to a universal
to see tonight's show yeah take my girl
cause she ate it saw red-state down in
Austin he says I thank you ma'am right
just want to see if Robbins is
intimidating a person as he was in the
film
see I am intimidating with your head
wind boys oh my goodness I'm gonna be
wrapping people in cellophane tonight
there's nothing if you haven't seen the
movie but in October you'll be laughing
your asses off trust me boilers more
Sean Connery nope sorry game show
category oh this is a good one this is
for Nate and Sarah and Jessica and Mark
Wow
right on man couples night it is couples
night my wife and I are attending our
first live Hollywood babble-on show to
celebrate my wife Sarah's 28th birthday
welcome my wife and I would love the
show I love the show and you do miss
solid if you wish her a happy birthday
in your truman capote voice wait I have
a Truman Capote voice this is the most
important so I can have a shot at some
butt sex yeah you know it's an all anal
policy here is Hollywood babble-on also
her best friend Jessica and her
boyfriend Mark he'll be joining us if
Kevin can use his awesome phone sex
voice to get mark and Jessica in the
right mood to finally show each other
their Oh faces and ride the boner roller
coaster together these two dudes want to
[ __ ] each other no no you wouldn't you
they want you to get mark and Jessica in
the mood to [ __ ] each other have mark
and Jessica not [ __ ] yet
well it's about time you - is this a co
really you guys haven't pulled around
yet well we I'm up here on kiss in front
of every yeah
have you guys never kissed before they
come up here kiss for everybody man I'll
jerk off slow come on up man like kiss
for the first time that's the first time
no they just haven't read them look are
we so happy about cuz they have it oh
that was the first time now they haven't
written the bone roller coaster together
yet
oh you haven't [ __ ] yet oh come up
here and [ __ ] for the first time oh
you're supposed to use your phone sex
voice to get him in the mood that was my
phone what is my phone's like just like
hey man is that the voice you're the
only one excited dude he's like that's
the one hold on oh do it man do it why
don't you guys come up here and kiss
come up here make it out let's see yeah
sorry you supposed to do truman capote
yes as a shot some butt sex oh my
goodness
you do having that anal sex yes I
recommend it highly
yeah oh my goodness that's not that's
just pooping that sounds like Jerry
Lewis
dude you're Truman Capote and you're
Jerry Lewis very similar gut dude Jerry
Lewis first to Truman Capote my name is
Truman Capote I wrote a novel caught in
cold blood
okay now - all right that's cheerful it
wigs you won you want the shoe is Jerry
long as you would tell us on Jerry Lewis
hits the sea well hey Jerry Lewis with
the ladies huh it's not the same thing
at all
you couldn't be more right Truman Capote
Thank You Jerry Lewis right time for
emails as always let's hear the email
song James hit it
[Music]
featuring
Kevin's reaction you can sell females at
Hawley that dude's sister I was on the
road where was that Chicago and she came
up to me and she's like my brother wrote
the song for the email I'm like one
she's like Babylon email song it's like
where they say my name she goes yeah he
said to say hi yeah yeah yeah I met her
sister she was cute yeah you can email
us at HBO podcasts at aol.com and you
can follow us on twitter at Ralph Garman
or at that Kevin Smith this comes from
Morgan Rangel in Aurora Colorado guys
that work in a candy store in a mall in
Aurora Colorado they asked me if I could
work on a sign for the stores front
window that would be fun for the kids I
couldn't think of what would be silly
and fun for kids to make them want to
come in and buy candy then one of the
greatest songs popped into my head
and hey she's butthole the kiddie
version now big a kids candy store I
couldn't have a butthole but what I
decided to do is have a winking brown
eye so here's a photo of a sign he put
in the front window of his candy store
says let's all go inside with a winking
brown eye I hope this beacon of butthole
will help me find listeners as well as
paying customers here in Aurora so Thank
You Morgan for putting that in the
window and I hope the authorities come
by to visit you soon they're luring
children into a candy store with butt
hole jokes
I'm Chris Hansen from Dateline NBC hey
Ralph and cab this email begins this is
John from Australia after listening to
John Lovitz on the second on his second
HBO appearance I couldn't help but feel
he reminded me of someone from my
childhood then it hit me
Skeletor the arch-nemesis of he-man and
the Masters of the Universe don't
believe me well he sent some video along
to confirm it here's some video
[Music]
well it is a little love obsessed he
says we need to be a big favor and do an
old-fashioned curse shoe he-man in love
it's his voice kiss you he met this one
comes from Roxane when I heard that Ralf
hates country music we covered this a
couple weeks ago I thought I'd make this
bumper sticker up for him so he can tell
the world this is the bumper sticker she
made up for me it's I hate and then [ __ ]
picture of Chelsea Handler tree and then
music on the other end of it see it's a
rebus eyes a rebus even if you can't
read you know your intent that's right
this one comes from Dustin in Ohio I
have a request that may be unprecedented
I was wondering if you could do me a
favor
on my wife's behalf and ask me to give
up the ass that's right she wants to peg
me that's interesting why you
celebrating over here I don't know I
think it's Faraday we're always talking
about ladies heaven but sex and I think
it's nice that ol Dustin from Ohio it's
ready to be the dude who's like I'll
take it for all of womankind
he's like a [ __ ] anal sex Jesus giving
it up for the rest of us man so that we
all might enter the kingdom of God yeah
that's a religion they may not want to
join pegging Jesus I feel like Edwin
assuring me that it would be okay would
give me comfort while being plowed by a
chick I think we've done enough Edwin
for tonight that give my shout out he's
giving up his ass oh my goodness Dustin
one suggestion I used lots of lubricant
because a torn [ __ ] don't get that
last forever
you know what that means we began with a
tenacious butthole let's close with that
this came from Tom Barsky he says I
thought you guys get a kick out of an
actual animated KITT show opening for an
hey she's butthole so I put together the
ante she's butthole cartoon and threw it
up on YouTube you can check it out
yourself if you want and hey she's
bought whole cartoon opening if you go
for that on YouTube you'll find it I'm
an editor and I figured I'd keep
something together for you guys to enjoy
state garmi strong this is Tom's actual
animated opening for the fictional kid
show and hey shoes butthole how much do
you know that's actual footage of a
colonoscopy in the center of the opening
there so we all did go inside I
appreciate the psycho stick yes let's
take a look at the headlines as always
we start off with tinsel town stiffs got
a lot of requests to bring back the evil
tinsel town stiff song for this
particular stiff so I thought we'd start
off with that James
[Music]
next ya sama bin Laden apparently this
week was taken out I didn't read a lot
about it so I'm not sure the details but
I think he was killed by a bionic dog
with titanium teeth that was the most
amazing part of the story turned out to
be wrong but that was an amazing force
that's really what I ran I thought a dog
had titanium teeth they did well yes and
no apparently when their teeth go bad
they can replace them with titanium but
not the way they made the story sound
the first time it's like we've taken
dogs taking their teeth out put in razor
titanium mouths and let them go [ __ ]
attack terrorists we were like this is
the [ __ ] future man this is like
[ __ ] t3 I was excited like a robot
dog or something absolutely I was so
into that I was just like oh my god I'll
die at the [ __ ] mouth of a robotic
metal mouth eating dog that'd be someone
to tell your kids about what you
wouldn't know it was exciting and then
it turns out no it turns out once or
twice if they lose a tooth they'll
replace it with a titanium replacement
but the initial report said that they
have these jaws of Steel that were used
to bite through like armor yeah right
it's not true what's I'm not nearly as
excited about the horrible terrorists
getting killed all right let's talk
about some nice people who also passed
away this week this is the good
tinseltown stand now
they will be missed they will be missed
Yvette Vickers will be missed she was a
former Playboy Playmate yeah 82 years
old she was also an actress she
co-starred in attack of the 50-foot
woman she played the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
steals away the husband of the 50-foot
woman gets that 50-foot woman all kinds
of pissed off totally well apparently
the 15-foot woman had her revenge
apparently years later turns out she was
found in her home near Los Angeles she
was found by a neighbor another actress
named Susan savage who seemed to notice
that the letters in Evette Vickers
mailbox had gone unopened for some time
the letters had started to yellow she
said there were cobwebs in the mailbox
turns out that 82 year old actress
Yvette Vickers had been dead for over a
year she was in a room with a space
heater on had it been on for a year and
her remains had become mummified that's
so Hollywood yeah oh my god man could
you imagine this is so sad she had
nobody nobody checked in on her nobody
knew for a year let's make a pact that
this will never happen all right
absolutely I'll check on you if I don't
hear from you in like a year so he said
the woman who powder said her remains
were unrecognizable yeah then how do
they know there were remains because she
had titanium teeth right yes this is a
photo of MS Vickers in her prime and
Playboy in 1959 yeah that's what I'm
talking about
playmate should never die that's what I
think we should find some sort of way to
keep them alive forever do you have the
after picture I decided not to include
the mummified remains picture oh that's
so sad it was nobody claimed or even
after her death no no relevance or no
friends just a home that apparently was
in disarray she lived in Benedict Canyon
you know up and it's all broken down and
were broken so she was living in squalor
pretty much good times all right welcome
to the comedy show you're gonna die one
day just like this stripper oh she will
mr. butt just like this playmate I don't
know if you're a Star Trek fan or not
but I was and I was sad to hear the
passing of William Campbell who was a
big deal in the Star Trek the original
series cannon he played two big roles on
the original series he played a
character named Trey Lane one of the
villains in the first season of Star
Trek an episode called the squire of
gothos and then more importantly he
played Captain Koloff in the trouble
with tribbles episode yeah he was he was
a smarmy Klingon this is before they had
the [ __ ] herpes on their forehead or
whatever they got going now
he was the smooth proud Klingon but
here's a little clip of William Campbell
I expect you to assume full
responsibility for the persecution of
pregnant Nationals in this apology yes
you've harassed by men you've treated
them like criminals you've been most fun
now if you wish to avoid if we're not
against Mel Kirk you can't let him that
would give them the weight they need to
claim Sherman's planet I believe that
more than the word of an aggrieved
Klingon commander would be necessary Oh
William Campbell he will be missed he
was he reprised the role in Deep Space 9
he came back and put on the bumpy head
and came back as a Klingon but he's been
working for 50 years in a bunch of
different shows so when did they do the
crew changeover from like normal-looking
Klingon next generation that's when the
worst time and I've had that brow no no
cuz wasn't in Star Trek oh the movies
yeah I thought you meant TV that's where
it happened though the first time we saw
Klingons with weirdness was in the movie
yeah nobody said anything no one has
ever addressed that really it's so
[ __ ] like I'm looking at that gun
that's not a Klingon that apparently is
a Klingon and they just one day they
were like yeah and then we're gonna
change it all Klingons look [ __ ] up
suck it up so straight yeah yeah you
seem a little Faye to me that that
Klingon little light in the loafers I'm
not saying anything
councillor Keats just you're just
treating us horribly my quite as
intimidating as a Klingon you know we
could either fight or I could suck your
dick that's right
I Jews McConkey I'm an evil [ __ ]
from outer space cuz they were from
outer space right they were yes everyone
was Star Trek a lot of spaceship yeah
that phaser for chiz
Sega Thompson passed away this week
eighty-three years old uh mercy doctor
she was the mom on family member family
Kristy McNichol yeah yeah shows like
nobody was very respected nobody was
really watched exactly not big ratings
but it was on 440 loves she was
nominated for four excuse me make sure
I'm right here for Emmys yeah for Emmys
and she finally won one in 78 so [ __ ] it
man the lone set of applause like yay
for the Emmy somebody somebody's not at
the funeral because they're here other
ones some television she was a big stage
star to in New York also that's where
she came from and this was the one who
really uh really stung me this week
Jackie Cooper former child star and of
course Perry White from the for Superman
movies with Christopher Reeve why did it
stun you because you thought he died
years ago
oh but that's what's made people like
Jackie Cooper's dead I'm like yeah he's
been dead for like ten years right like
no because he was one of those guys that
I always looked up to because of the
length and breadth of his career this
guy did it all that should you say the
length and breadth of this guy I knew
that's what you're gonna think the
minute the words came out of my mouth I
knew you were thinking [ __ ] no this guy
let me get listen this is why I'm glad
we do this segment yes that's funny
don't get me wrong it's kind of
depressing but it's kind of cool to look
back on some of the slides I agree and
Jackie Cooper started off as a child
star he was in the little rascals the
our gang comedies when he was a little
kid then he went on to do feature films
in the 30s he was nominated for an Oscar
a Best Actor Oscar at the age of nine to
this day he's still the youngest nominee
ever for a Best Actor Oscar right on
went on to be a teen actor did that
movie the champ with wallace Beery about
the box remember that every one they
remade
Treasure Island he was in that he did a
bunch of TV in the 50s and in the 60s he
became a TV executive here and ran
television for Columbia Pictures
Television that's kind of Wick
responsible for getting shows like
bewitched on the air then in the 70s he
started directing television won two
Emmys for episodes of mash and the white
shadow that he directed then he got back
into acting and became Perry White in
the Superman movies oh man those dudes
it makes me feel like a slacker yeah
that's what I'm talking about
I like that I like that he switched
careers a couple times that's a tribute
here's a little piece of him playing
Perry White in Superman Jackie Cooper he
will be mess we just did the memoriam
segment at the Emmys funny man you know
when they run those clips and everybody
you know it's very silent until the end
and they applaud yeah so we comes out
and sings a sad song you felt like that
yeah there's like smile when mother
[ __ ] at da hey new releases this week
as we all knew she would Jodie Foster
directed a movie called the beaver
she finally got around to it comes out
this weekend and limited release Mel
Gibson plays a troubled executive who
adopts a hand puppet as his only way of
communicating with his friends and
family then he proceeds to beat the [ __ ]
out of him with a beaver puppet on his
hand
I feel like this this was a gimmick that
I've seen in that movie and I think
we've talked about it before the I think
it was called Sydney white the movie
with a Amanda chick from The Amanda Show
and Nickelodeon what's her name
fine fine she was in this movie called
the Sydney white which I think it's
called Sydney way there's this
snow-white NACO alright and she lived
with some dudes and on a campus and one
of the dudes this was the whole [ __ ]
movie he had up he couldn't deal with
people so he talked to her puppet so
then I've read this description I was
like they stole this from an Amanda
Bynes movie Jodie Foster is a big Amanda
Bynes fan thank you will now shout it
out that's all I'm saying it's all I'm
asking just think it through before you
shout it out I was clearing out the
sister [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jumping the Broom opens this weekend the
story of two african-american families
one from uptown one from downtown oh
they sure mismatched these two families
I bet there's chaos at the wedding I got
one of my favorite tweets of all time
yeah I think it was on Friday somebody
wrote random out of nowhere how stoked
are you for jumping the broom
that made me laugh for five minutes
somewhere Tyler Perry's banging his head
against the wall saying [ __ ] what did I
think of this can't Madea stop by the
wedding say words wrong and [ __ ]
Something Borrowed also opens this
weekend Jennifer Goodwin Kate Hudson
played two best friends in love with the
same guy oh I bet they learned important
lessons about life and love this is
opening today yeah it sure is
Wow yeah I just saw posted for this in
the Beverly Center bro I have no
awareness this movie whatsoever but the
one under it because they Something
Borrowed refers to the apply I think
that's where the yes and you've seen it
I went to the premiere
did you yeah it was pretty cool wow
you're out of town oh my list
I'm just get hammered why you I oughta
yeah went to the premiere which was
worth it just to see kat dennings tits
jay went as well they went attached to
her Wow
but she showed up an address it was just
all just struggling under the weight of
them yes was one of those big premieres
it was it more Loki Loki Loki
when I got no reaction to that joke the
first time that felt really Thor tell us
about the movie dude I haven't seen the
enema go tomorrow ass guarded as I am
I'm surprised I didn't see that joke
coming love it it's great I saw the film
it's amazing it is maybe my second or
third favorite comic book movie of all
yeah that's strong yeah great cast this
Chris Hemsworth he's a [ __ ] movie star
this guy right yeah he's greatest door
and I saw him in person speak like
verily and shoot not so much a little
bit of that but they toned it down which
i think is a good idea cuz he wasn't
like an [ __ ] you know it reads good
in the comics anybody heard somebody
walking around New Mexico saying verily
I want to go with to Denny's and have
the Grand Slam breakfast upon ye morning
sir
oh it sound off you're right there you
shouldn't be little talking about no
moons over my hammy and a Thor movie now
he is a 6'5 this kid and just huge and
so is Kirk's dad and the Star Trek
remake yeah but like 40 pounds of muscle
on I did and it moved a little bit I'm
telling you as I watched he's that girl
yeah yeah yeah I've noticed the two
she's like who is this who is this Thor
person and I was a call from the comics
she wears the helmet she goes no the one
who plays them
my cell just leave the room yeah a
little some I heard she's singing the
Friday Anthony Hopkins is Odin the
all-father
yes great stuff all the ask arts that
plays like Shakespeare because he's
British and Chris Hemsworth and what is
a snore don't spoil spoil it spoilers if
you haven't seen it is Asgard Norse
mythology Asgard are they like where
aliens from outer space Asgard yes
clarify to all the above well they they
were the protectors of the nine realms
yes and earth being one of those back in
the olden times they protect Earth from
the frost giants right and the the north
jeolla chick oh oh I might watch this
game is check so they were there when
the Norse roamed the earth
yes and so they were so powerful because
they were aliens that the Norse thought
of them as gods the story was handed
down as they were gods
but then they left because their their
job there was done right they left and
just lived on in mythology so in essence
they work gods to the Norse but in
reality they were where the helmet he
does where the hell we got a lot no
mostly just for you know the royal
wedding and stuff now when he dresses up
he puts a nice hat on goes to see
William and Kate tie the knot
how is Loki look he's good I don't know
that at all he's in a ton yeah really
he's the man and a bad guy from the
beginning oh yeah oh really well not
really you're kind of a sucker you in
you know he's like his brother and oh I
love you brother and why does he change
his brother touched him in the shower
yeah exactly yeah barely heard the bunk
beds going the new Thor was waxing the
hammer didn't care for it I hate you
Thor natalie portman plays Jane Foster
in the house she she's great on it
what's just always good kat dennings
plays the sexy funny little sidekick
good you saw her boobs in the movie no
try that the premiere in the red carpet
yeah I interview the booth is that uh
low left hello right how are you tonight
anthony hopkins by the way was at the
premiere and how is she in the movie cat
things very very cute is she that's her
job I've seen a lot of like uh
punchlines with her a lot of clips from
the movie where she's no comic really
yeah being a little saucy or someone
yeah but Anthony Hopkins is amazing in
the film but in real life he went to the
the line there where every was at the
premiere where all the fans had lined up
on the barricades and must have stood
there for a half an hour 45 minutes sign
autographs and chicken handsome really
yeah it was pretty cool the guy of that
caliber being being that cool to the
crowd so he's probably out there going
like guy thanks no he wasn't
why do you have to ruin everything
that's what I do it hey man how are you
kind of joint I don't want to be here
Hollywood headlines Lindsay Lohan
started her 480 hours of community
service this week at the Downtown
Women's Center and here's how she was
dressed on her first day I've got a
little picture of her she went in short
shorts and braless and a black tank top
to the downtown woman center well he's a
woman's Center yeah she's looking for a
date I think that's why she's dressing
that way
good to see she's got Coke in her hands
people were saying she was dressed
inappropriately for you know community
service work at a woman center but she
should have been dressed more
conservatively Alfred dick she's got a
dick why why like why are people bust
her balls about what she's [ __ ]
wearing to do community service it's
like she's doing her time get off her
balls well I think it's it's defensible
because usually service for Lindsay
Lohan means taking care of three dudes
for an Eightball on a pool table in the
back of Chateau Marmont so she was
dressed for service she bought and it
turned out to be a different kind of
service so she was confused a lot of
celebrity births this week Bryan Adams
remember him Bryan Adams cuts like a
knife Bryan Adams everything I do for
you Robert hood yeah for a while there
he we had a song in like every movie
that came out and he had the three have
you ever ever really really really
Don Juan DeMarco are you asking me
no I'm singing the roots yeah a song
about a bass
I remember lyrics correctly Manor [ __ ]
was a little stinky at the five-and-dime
when you think 69 you go right to the
ass these bad manners to [ __ ]
completely useless I'm just an ass man
yeah yeah I know where my bread's
buttered Brian out is what about him man
51 years old I'm sorry got wrapped up in
your ass at 51 years old he's a
first-time dad at 51 he's never had a
kid never had a kid before nohow
apparently the mother is his personal
assistant Alicia she's a sista his
gonads
apparently the baby is named baby was
born on April the 22nd mirabela Bunny is
her middle name bunny it's [ __ ] up I
got a whole list of [ __ ] up celebrity
names here I'd like to go through a lot
of births this week okay Antonio sabato
jr. remember him no I don't either but
uh he was a heartthrob for a minute I
guess in the 80s or 90s or something
what was he on the Melrose Place or
something this is Antonio sabato jr.
soap opera something what happened
underwear ads there you go apparently
good-looking fella heat his wife Cheryl
the girl that was the one that hasn't
[ __ ] that guy oh I got interested in
their story again what's usually
underwear ads like
there because their hands like right on
his leg unfairly she's too busy taking
care of herself two pictures of guys in
underwear and not enough real man in her
life too much fantasy dude you need to
shift your chair a little bit and then
that hand just moves yeah there we go
Antonio and his wife Cheryl had a baby
boy over the weekend
this is his name Antonio that's
Antonio's name fairness is his middle
name Comic Con Aloha Mike Kalani Harvey
zapato the third Antonio comic-con Aloha
Maya Kalani Harvey sabato the third
Antonio says the Hawaiian middle name
means a beloved gift from the heavens I
looked it up and actually it is Hawaiian
for getting your ass kicked every
lunchtime in the schoolyard I've got two
other kids mouth full mouth yeah that's
[ __ ] up yeah it is I mean I should
never judge other kids but comic-con
alone but that is a [ __ ] mouth yeah
he's gonna get a mouthful
speaking of which J Moore and his wife
Nikki Cox mm-hmm brought home a
brand-new baby boy this week baby boy
named Meredith Moore Meredith Daniel
Moore is his name really yeah wasn't I
was thinking I was gonna say wasn't John
Wayne's name Meredith but it's Marion
Marion Marion Morrison yeah I don't know
any man named Meredith Burgess burgess
Meredith that was the last name totally
man yeah anyone so he's gonna have to
get real tough real word a nickname but
well obviously Meredith Daniel more the
probably could calm Danny if that's the
case why don't they call him Daniel
Meredith more than Barry the Barry the
[ __ ]
like I'm sure they're like Sean
McConnell oh I'm out of Kalani their kid
is [ __ ] and the king and queen of
[ __ ] [ __ ] up names for your kids
Mariah Carey and Nick Cannon revealed
their baby names this week they had
twins last weekend the son is named
Moroccan cannon Moroccan Scot cannon
apparently the top room in Mariah's
multi level New York City apartment is
called the Moroccan room and they loved
that room so much they named their son
Moroccan I wonder where that kid was
conceived
well apparently Nick did proposed to his
wife in the Moroccan room so that room
has a lot of meaning for them if I name
my kid after the room she was conceived
be called bathroom toilet meet my
daughter bathroom toilet Smith we expect
great things from her yeah Moroccan
Morocco secret you must be very careful
you're trying to keep a secret
I just have a record the record of that
yeah that was good - together secret we
must gone they're trying to kill us we
have to be very careful secretive you
could do anything round
[Music]
Oh Peter Lorre Greek you must Hank me
reek
they trying to get me reek no no was
about the main pressure
tell me I'm good the Moroccan the name
for the kid they're saying the nickname
is rock rock they just had this kid
correct yes how the [ __ ] do you know the
nickname back quickly because they knew
was [ __ ] they they build it in yes
anticipation I like that the daughter
name is something that naturally occurs
how do they know it ain't gonna be Maury
or [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah the daughter's name is Monroe
because mariah has always had a
fascination with man up there's like one
as if that was the weird name so
Moroccan and Monroe
apparently Mariah has always had a
fascination with Marilyn Monroe and so
she is she's calling her Monroe Canon
now Monroe doesn't have a middle name
because Mariah herself does not have a
middle name she's one of those and
people on the birth certificate would
say Mariah and M and Cary no never know
middle names yeah Scott motors one of
those my friend Scott Mosier has well no
actually it was gonna be n MN and then
his dad said that's too many letters
just put a and they were what they stand
for and he said nothing that was so his
middle name is a yeah
Scott comma a Mosier
mariah said she doesn't have a middle
name so she didn't want her daughter to
have one either so I guess just pass
along all your [ __ ] traits to your
kids maybe she would like to have a
middle name maybe thought it was
different maybe they've got her like a
middle name and the ability to say no at
a buffet maybe she would like to share
some traits that her mother doesn't have
mine she heavy oh yeah even before she
was pregnant she was fat really yeah
Chozen is like that's all better
appearances stuff yeah really
oh she's a lot fried chicken and stuff
yeah some of her videos they had to
digitally alter her weight they had to
stretch her out in her videos to make
her look thinner it's absolutely true
that fried chicken was really fun thank
you I appreciate you really nice red
cheek oh sorry ladies Henry Cavill the
new Superman he's engaged to his
girlfriend Ellen Whittaker yeah they got
engaged this week what the [ __ ] he
thinking by the way he's gonna be
Superman but he's gonna get all the
[ __ ] in the world he's gonna be a
big-time movie star he could lay anybody
he wants he's gonna get engaged now
getting yeah now right before it takes
the plunge you don't get he's now get
engaged when they kick you out of
Superman for having a drug problem or
something and you're in the downside you
didn't want me to take care of you yes
they're on the upswing now you get
married when you're Lorenzo Lamas yeah I
could lead naming my next story he used
to be on Falcon Chris when I was a kid I
was wondering how we knew his name
Falcon Crest is when I was like a
nighttime soap along the lines of like a
not slanting or at Dallas I remember him
as the jock in grease that Olivia
newton-john goes out with to make Danny
Zuko jealous he's in that yeah he plays
the the the mute Jack I don't think he
has any lines in that movie Wow he's
like the Caleb of grease he's 53 his new
bride is 24
this is his fifth marriage he's got six
kids from four previous wives
he's living gay that's it he was also
the running he was renegade everybody
was red
yeah syndicated show he would drive a
motorcycle know who his hair flowing in
the wind
yeah rebelling against everything that's
how you knew he's a renegade and use a
scrunchie man he had his own [ __ ]
rules just let that hair go wasn't his
dad like Fernando Hernando Lamas that's
right my friend that wasn't Billy Chris
you're a marvelous my friend he's got
six kids from four previous wives his
oldest daughter Shane is older than his
new wife love is strange I want to be
there for Thanksgiving I want to see
Charlie Sheen's single ladies he's
officially single
the divorce came through this week oh
the single ladies run they have released
the details of the divorce agreement
with Brooke Mueller apparently she gets
fifty five thousand dollars a month in
child support but considering how much
he has is that a lot well he has less
and less every day I know that much
that's true and the deal was that he
couldn't give her any less than he gives
Denise Richards for his other kids that
was the agreement so that's why he has
to give her fifty five thousand a month
which means he's given to these Richards
fifty five thousand a month that's carry
the one a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a month the child support
expense that's a lot to carry man yeah
absolutely you're blowing most of it on
[ __ ] cocaine that's right
he gave her a one-time payment of 750
$7,000 and a million dollars for her
share in their home that they had
together what do you mean a one-time
payment that's like her pay up that's
her settlement in terms of the spousal
support she he still has to do the 55 a
child off word until they're 18 so how
long were they together I don't think it
says here but not very long right hello
drivers yeah she gets how much for that
$750,000 757 thousand and 1 million that
was 1 million so 1.7 million dollars
would you [ __ ] Charlie Sheen for a
couple years for that man though he
would that's the dude who's getting
married
well Charlie could be looking soon so
I'll pass along your phone numbers sir
and as we look at prenups and true love
this story came out this week and I
thought this is love it turns out that
when guy ritchie married madonna she was
deep into the Kabbalah stuff which is a
sect of Judaism but also involves magic
yeah numbers and magic urology in some
ways but yeah it's mysticism yeah you
pull rabbits out of a yarmulke or
something in this religion so Guy
Ritchie being a Brit and all yes wasn't
circumcised he had one of those huge
uncut European [ __ ] how do you know it
was huge why you think saying it on the
side I just got a su that sounds good
when you say uncut you gotta say huge
uncut cuz that sounds sexy that's how I
sell my dick to people before they see
it I'm like it's huge and uncut I whip
it out and they're like you're such a
big fat liar you're neither huge nor
undone yeah yeah anyway because she was
Jewish yes Guy Ritchie had to get
circumcised before they got married
Oh which as an adult is an enormous ly
painful problem
yeah he's also got a scar his face
doesn't that's how big his [ __ ] was I
had to start cutting at his face
get all the foreskin off its the reason
it was attached they used to look like a
mall or something and anyway when he got
divorced how pissed was he by the way do
you think when they get divorced put it
back on give me back me full skin I miss
it
like a badge it should have been in this
that should have been the settlement I
want my skin back yeah he was too late
she had already turned it into a concert
costume that's what true love in the new
Jean Jacques a boar and her husband are
trying to have a baby oh I read the
judge like a boar by the way is in the
hospital on death's door with pneumonia
and one leg her husband Prince Frederick
von all halt
I'm sure his last name is enough but
that's how it came out he's trying to
have a baby being a surrogate and the
news came out today that he asked David
Hasselhoff's ex-wife to carry the baby
for them okay but can I just take a step
back real quick I wish you would if he's
providing the sperm yes and some
surrogate is providing the egg and the
womb well that it's not supposed to work
that way there's nothing like what does
John's I have to do with any of this um
she's got the cash yeah I guess right
like she they keep saying like they're
trying to have a baby but she's probably
not I mean she's not involved in any way
shape form sounds like I'm guessing at
94 she doesn't have many eggs less than
sands
it's weird man well you got it you
wonder if she's even involved in a
certain point well I think you may have
be onto something because she confirmed
a David Hasselhoff ex-wife confirmed it
and he she said that he told her that
she would like to have you he would like
to have her jeans added to the mix for
their child so I think he just wants to
[ __ ] her basically I mean essentially
yeah I've been watching this story and
I'm like wait it just sounds like he
wants to [ __ ] somebody and she's 47 by
the way
Pamela Hasselhoff right so she's not
exactly the most viable candidate to
have a baby either I think they want to
have an adult that's what I'm thinking I
know you want to have a child they want
to take an 84 a 94 year old woman's egg
and put it in a 47 year old woman and
come out with an adolescent that's what
they like to have nice Mike the
situation from Jersey Shore just
announced this week he's getting his own
TV show on MTV this thing's still going
though it's getting a spinoff show as is
Snooki and JWoww and DJ Pauly D they're
all getting their own shows and part of
the deal is they keep doing the Jersey
Shore shows so we're gonna see four or
five shows with them in it every season
thank God they don't play music videos
anymore cuz now they've got all that air
time for a [ __ ] every spin-off of the
Jersey Shore NTV New Jersey teeth in a
related story
Angelina from that show she is pregnant
presumably by her boyfriend Dave Kovacs
they were engaged but are no longer
engaged Dave Kovacs told the press this
weekend that he broke up with Angela
Angelina rather the reason she was
sleeping around surprise surprise here's
his story I got a text from a
firefighter who actually apologized for
sleeping with Angelina saying he just
found out we were engaged he also added
that he found a pair of guy's underwear
in her car that was the final straw
right classy
where'd you go your mind just shatter
somebody good I got it with the human
right I really am I'm just I'm getting
worn down every week we talk about these
people it started really starting to get
to me
really I'm gonna I'm gonna have to start
getting a blowgun and just putting darts
in people this is the easiest way to
deal with that all right thank you
just don't look at that man oh why we're
talking about people that I hate Justin
Bieber first of all let me give a
shout-out to the Australian garmi who
showed up in force apparently at the
Justin Bieber concert in Sydney
Australia this week where Justin was
pelted with eggs while he was on stage
[Applause]
so weird who it was it was at a concert
his concert
someone paid cash money for a ticket and
then brought eggs in and threw them at
him on stage that's [ __ ] commitment
commitment level I can respect whipping
eggs at anybody come on here is socially
a little boy soft on me what it must do
for his self-esteem against hit by an
egg goes backstage like I wish they
liked me I just wish he had been a hit
here's some advice for the Australian
garmi a little warm up in the parking
lot before you actually go into the
theater six eggs were thrown not one hit
their target get out of here really
here's the footage from Australian news
of Justin Bieber being pelted with eggs
and you'll see they all miss him pop
star Justin Bieber has come under attack
from flying eggs the teen superstar was
performing his Sydney's Ice Arena last
night when six of them came into nowhere
you can see 284 first
thousands of doghouse gaming fans were
apparently not enough to deter the a
throne I hope it ain't enough to miss
before the show went on oh he's dancing
around the eggs missing he's like he's
like a [ __ ] ninja duck temper he's
like neo up there man
I throw an axe he's seeing zeros and
ones I'm just saying it's [ __ ]
Australia couldn't they get some emu
eggs or ostrich egg or couldn't they
don't they've some bigger eggs down
there platypus eggs or something bigger
eggs maybe the end I might do it now
they're gonna be searching us for eggs
when we go into the concert now it's
ruined we had one shot so going to get a
chance to take out a Hitler and you know
we had the chance it was like Valkyrie
who Tom Cruise in a patch on his I had
one chance to take him out and they fit
up
bummer rob lowes got an autobiography
out finally I can read Rob Lowe's story
he talks about on the set of The
Outsiders there were a lot of fisticuffs
going on see fisticuffs
like a gay no punching fighting oh just
fighting each other
Rob Lowe got into a fight with Tom
Cruise they came to blows Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise came to blows wink-wink and
Emilio Estevez also had a fight with Rob
Lowe really yeah what you see him all
shirtless grappling and [ __ ] like that
man and then he dances like a Maxine and
[ __ ] Breakfast Club all like angry
Emilio does that air punching aah
shatters glass and what not sexy
the only person they didn't fight they
say was Patrick Swayze who apparently
was too tough for any of them to take
Rob Lowe says he was too gnarly to fight
minute he smelled no he was too tough he
was a man's man they said my take your
mom yeah cuz he was all dancey and
whatnot man [ __ ] Brighton Beach I want
you to be nice until it's time not to be
nice good Roadhouse
I remember the movie yeah Payne don't
hurt pain don't hurt that's a movie dude
that was real he also played a
transvestite in to Wong foo that's true
maybe that's why they met by two gnarly
I guess let me once on nails they dress
with boobs yeah Rob also adds in his
autobiography that he has no regrets
about that video that came out in 1989
there was him having sex with a 16 year
old girl I don't know if anybody in the
audience would remember 1989 but yeah I
remember that there was a sex tape that
was released probably the first
celebrity sex tape that I remember yeah
of the modern age that's for sure
Rob Lowe having sex with a 16 year old
girl I believe it was at a political
convention or something a political
caucus or something he was working at
political caucus he says he doesn't
regret the decision at all well I guess
he doesn't he [ __ ] the 16 year old and
got away with it got away with it
no he didn't get in trouble eating good
prosecutor no but he said it led him
straight to rehab and now he's got 20
years of sobriety under his belt all
right
quitter Annie [ __ ] the 16 year old and
didn't get arrested
and he apparently [ __ ] Tom Cruise at
one point right they came to blows while
we're talking about inappropriate
touching former Miss USA Susie Castillo
was all over the internet this week
complaining about an overzealous pact
down by a TSA employee apparently she
was at the dallas-fort Worth
International Airport and she claims a
TSA female agent got a little too
touchy-feely when she got patted down
yeah
let's bring the lights down tell the
story again really a woman yeah James
let's get a little sexy feet going man
so we can tell this story again Susie
didn't want to go through the scanner
because she's afraid of radiation okay
so she opted for the pat-down mm-hmm
now she said she had been patted down
before I bet she had but this pat-down
went too far we got some videotape of
Susie talking about the pat-down herself
if you'd like to see it okay here we go
you were molested sweetheart trust me
who is she talking to she filmed herself
in the airport effort happened and put
it up on the Internet
that's how upset she was she had to stop
and make a movie that pissed off that is
she seemed kind of intense about both
yeah but I don't do that machine either
I just got the pat-down I was flying
back and I don't like to go through that
because it takes a naked picture of you
and I have a tiny dick right so I don't
want that on any hard drive anywhere so
I show they said go through here I said
no no I won't go through the other one
this is then you're gonna get the
pat-down and I said well I want the
pat-down and they patted me down and I
came and it felt good oh but think about
it if you're a woman and you're
smuggling a bomb in some how would you
know where you gonna put it III do you
really think that the that she was being
molested by a female agent no I no I
think she was just probably doing her I
think she former Miss USA and she's a
little prissy pants and someone touched
her hoo-ha and she got all upset right I
think she liked it that's right madam I
agree that's why it was too upset I'll
show her molestation yours the
molestation you come to this show young
lady just evil we're in support of that
Ralph they were like [ __ ] Dementors
man
and you were like their Voldemort and
they were circling around you and she
was to be patted down dark see him after
the show legal news yes Tallulah Belle
Willis got in trouble with the law this
week oh no she is the seventeen-year-old
daughter of Bruce Willis and to me more
she apparently was that's the youngest
correct she's 17 years old I believe
that's the last of the Demi Moore Bruce
Willis kids because rumor is older yeah
no she's like 15
right yeah I think yeah I think so
Tallulah and three friends were leaving
a car with booze in their hands cop
noticed them pulled them over they were
all minors in the possession and
apparently mom had to come down to bail
them out really yeah Bruce wanted to
break them out of jail I heard that's
what he wanted to do he wanted to put
some c4 right up against the wall to
sell blow it had a helicopter waiting
job this but nothing happened so
although if Bruce was your dad wouldn't
you drink that's what I'm thinking no
comment okay get something out of him
could you imagine [ __ ] like you're
the cop and you pull those kids over and
one of them as that kid and you're like
one of their parents is gonna come so
I'm gonna meet a movie star that's right
and you're just hoping that it's it's
[ __ ] Demi Moore yeah as opposed to
meeting him because and you get her out
of bed and she's like in a nightshirt or
total it's like oh my god I'm doing one
of my boobs is hanging out I just got
out of bed let me run back my high heel
that's all I had to put on with my high
heels in this underwear did I forget my
g-string whatever he's that big
fantastic
Starsky was in court this week from
Starsky and Hutch Paul Michael Glaser
yeah
68 year-old Paul Michael was in court
because he's trying to get a restraining
order against a stalker it's the woman
who used to run his official website now
she's stalking him he claims she's
irrational he fears for his safety he's
a big star but not to the judge while in
court the judge asks Paul Michael Glaser
please describe your TV experience
because the judge had to claim he had no
idea who he was a judge didn't recognize
the Starsky Wow
that's what I'm like you know what
what's this up he's a stalker somebody
who knows who I am I'll say I'm one of
the biggest [ __ ] television shows in
the history of television mine so much
so that even people who weren't alive
then know that show know the name they
don't know it well but they've heard the
name and this judge is never [ __ ]
heard of this guy mr. Glaser could you
please tell me who the [ __ ] you are and
why this crazy woman wants to be so near
you I was started 68 dude I might not
recognize him either anyway he got his
restraining order so now his last fan
has been banged from the hill that's
kind of sad Phil Spector's appeal to
have his murder conviction overturned
was rejected yesterday come on Phil's
innocent right he of course is serving a
19 years to life sentence for the murder
of actress Lana Clarkson Phil still
maintains that his wig was the one who
pulled the trigger he was the creator of
the wall of sound he was he was one of
the biggest music producers in the world
in the sixties and seventies he's in
jail now using Jail to meet a wall of
rape
Andy Dick can't stay out of trouble he
was arrested for drunk and disorderly
conduct
at a Marie Callender's that may be the
saddest [ __ ] thing I've ever heard
I'm mad at these PI's how hard up do you
have to be to get loaded at a Murray
County what a [ __ ] bonus night that
would be to be eating at the Marie
Callender's have you know you don't go
all the time but every once in a while I
like I feel like pie let's go to Marie
Callender's and then somebody's always
like are you [ __ ] high and you're
like yeah let's go to Marie Callender's
and the other eating that [ __ ] pint
I'll listen to Andy Dick flips the [ __ ]
out
I'd be like pie for everyone brave I
love Hollywood you another slice of that
rum raisin [ __ ] up at Marie
Callender's they have pie and gravy
don't you things they serve out [ __ ] me
up
what did he do he apparently was
harassing employees with a load on I've
heard he's very touchy when he gets
drunk ro and cops had to be called
because I don't know he wouldn't stop
handling the news Jason Mewes I guess
lived near him or around him he says
he's a really nice guy he says but he's
so there's no barrier or perimeter
between people Smith says it'll come in
to his house like awesome he'll be
musically playing a game and you know
like hey Jason they'll turn around Andy
Dick stand to give it's living room with
a pie he'll come right up to him no and
he's just like hey man do you have
anything and Muse is just like no man no
why are you so close he's just like why
does it bother you sounds like an
interesting cat does it'll ease and
lastly Rick Springfield was arrested
this week Oh drunk driving he's going to
jail well he was arrested for the
suspicion of drunk driving he's still
got a face court but he was pulled over
on the PCH here in Southern California
in his 1963 Corvette
mm-hmm he was driving with a blood
alcohol level of 0.1 oh and the legal
limit is point zero eight so he was over
the limit and he's gonna have a court
date on July 5th I can't stress this
enough people take a take a page out of
his book and do not drink and drive a
really cool classic car yeah if you're
gonna drink a drive get yourself a
[ __ ] beater
that's just your drinking car that's
what I do I've got a nice Mustang I
leave that at home when I go out and get
loaded I have like like a Chevy Impala
from the 70s and I have actually
strapped spare tires to the the
perimeter of it it's like a bumper car
and I'll just get shit-faced but I'm
pretty sure I will bounce off of
anything pretty much anything that I run
into on the way ha so you don't take
your 63 vet out on a bender it's just
poor planning on Rick Springfield's Park
I have never heard the concept of the
drinking cup oh yeah
keep a spare just to go out a fake ahead
okay why I drink do you think he goes to
jail for something like that probably
not I believe it's his first offense
he'll probably have to do some community
service hopefully with Lindsay Lohan or
tits hanging out hey can you believe how
much money the [ __ ] Fast Five movie
made how much it make eighty-five
million dollars in a new film again
really yes I've not seen any of those
movies so I can't be like how is that
possible they must be good they're not
no no didn't do they give out [ __ ]
with the movie no I it's lost on me then
why is it makes so much I don't know
people want to see people in cars
driving around [ __ ] people like Vin
Diesel I guys know they don't dude how
is it making them I don't know but those
aren't the answers
all right aliens all right I'll take ya
85 million dollars in its opening
weekend surprise surprise they've
announced this week that there will be a
fast six here's that here's the truth of
this franchise man the last not the one
that just came out with the one before
it
yeah was that that was fast four or the
Fast and the Furious fastest and the
most furious faster and even more
furious sir it was the one without
what's-his-face he'd been out for a
little while bindis now the last one had
been he came back for the right rep but
he wasn't in it until the very very end
or something like that was that the one
there was one that they did I think
Justin Lin who directed this three three
with Tokyo Drift so at the very end he
comes back when they test screen that
movie I have friends who were in that
but involved in the process that were
just like I've never seen a reaction so
[ __ ] religious like when he popped up
at the end he was like let's race or
whatever the [ __ ] he said or like
Superman I didn't see it but they he
said the [ __ ] place erupted it got a
hundred percent based on that moment
alone at that point Universal was just
about to mothball the franchise and
maybe do straight-to-video and they were
like let's do one more
he's like us and then that [ __ ] took
off and reignited it so we're gonna be
with these cars for like ten movies I
think I don't know cuz Vin Diesel said
he is done being an action star was he
gonna do instead he says with age you
get to a place where you don't want to
knock people out you want to give people
a hug there's no money and hug there's
no money in hugging no wow
you'll be back Dwayne the rock Johnson
he was in that movie right was in that
movie added to the box office I think as
a lot of people like the rock they do
he's beloved them except when he's doing
those hockey movies but for kids
oh the tooth fairy [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
wouldn't beloved them and and the ones
the football one too we had the little
girls showed up in his doorstep it was
his long-lost daughter - it's out of
money - on my dog I've done this in a
while but I think it's time doing the
right John has just announced his next
project so it's time for something we
haven't done in a while it's my
Hollywood doom for now Ralph Gardens
[Music]
Dwayne the rock Johnson has just
announced his next film it will be a
biopic of the country music star Charlie
pride I know who that is Charlie pride
was the first black country and western
singer Kissin angel good morning and
legend the letter no you think about it
when you go funny you should say that I
brought in a little Charlie private was
that Chloe you're very close here's a
little clip of the actual Charlie pride
singing that song that was his number
one hit
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
like Kissin angel good morning and lover
like the devil when you get back home
that's a song about a no realm no it's
not yes it is Charlie private wrote the
first country-western song about a old
man Callay anil nice anil like married
anil like kiss her goodbye respect her
when you come back it's hell on earth no
one wants to see a movie about that dude
least of all they want to see the rock
in a in a purple glitter suit singing
that [ __ ] song that's the other thing
the rock is like ten feet taller than
charlie yeah and about four shades
lighter it would be akin to me going I'm
gonna play Gretzky in a movie just
whiskey something somebody might want to
see though Charlie pride no one gives a
[ __ ] good I mean I know he was the first
black country star so you do have the
scene where there's some redneck in a
pickup going on he's would you get that
moment the guy listening on the radio
right kissing me I like this up what the
[ __ ] you say what he's a would well I've
learned something about myself I change
my mind I like black people now no one
wants to see this amenda I want to see
Hollywood doom I'm predicting Hollywood
do I know the last time you did this it
was for Green Hornet yeah it didn't pan
out so well while we're talking about
Dwayne the rock Johnson he is being
credited as one of the first people to
tweet the news that Osama bin Laden was
dead really yes can you believe that he
had inside information he tweeted it
eight minutes a full eight minutes
before the CBS reporter did that was
currently being credited with breaking
the news in the news industry he was
there he had a dog with titanium teeth
and he went over the wall that's why
they won't tell us who took the kill
shot because they would like rock it was
the rock like how awesome is that
The Rock killed bin Laden he found out
somehow from some source before anybody
else knew his tweet read just got word
that will shock the world land of the
free home of the brave damn proud to be
an American what do you think of Charlie
pride no but apparently he says he was
the first guy to talk about Obama's
death on Twitter that's strange
Pepi be wrong samus yeah Wow Secret
Service can bust it in here in a minute
this is interesting this is just an
interesting back don't expect any laughs
but Twitter recorded an average of three
thousand tweets per second during 10:45
and 2:20 a.m. at the time when the news
broke that's amazing yeah that's the
first of a you know worldwide hated
individual that's been killed in the age
of social media it would be like what
would it be like if Hitler was killed if
we had Twitter or Miley Cyrus or Twitter
people talk about that I guess I'm just
saying now that we've got a I'm proud to
be an American over this you got Osama
out of the way Bieber's being pelted
with eggs we're going along the right
road she seems to be going away herself
Miley said oh this [ __ ] [ __ ] you see
the latest news this week and the home
video out of Ecuador where she was in
concert in Ecuador as you decide to be a
good idea to cover smells like teen
spirit
do you have video why Kevin I'm glad you
asked
here's Miley covering smells like teen
spirit by Nirvana
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first of all she dances like Elaine from
Seinfeld that's right but more
importantly she led into the song saying
a lot of fans have come up to me and
tell me that I inspire them and make
them want to follow their dreams so on
this tour I want to be able to do the
music that inspired me and made me want
to be on this stage here tonight Nirvana
nirvana inspired her [ __ ] [ __ ] do
you think she was even alive with
Nirvana no I don't think she was alive
when Kurt Cobain was alive
what is she 17 how long he's been dead
years right yeah she's not she what
didn't grab a guitar and start busking
in some terminal someplace playing for
nickels and dimes she put on a [ __ ]
wig sang party in the usa' [ __ ]
unacceptable cannot happen fair enough
we'll make sure she wears a flannel
shirt next he's on the list casting news
Arnold Schwarzenegger has chosen his
first movie since being The Terminator
wait since the first movie will not be a
new Terminator so it's not happening no
he's not doing the Terminator he's doing
a movie but it's not the turtle first
they said it was gonna do a terminator
not doing terminator but now it's not
doing true no he's left the governorship
his first movies gonna be called cry
macho which is about Rob Lowe fighting
Tom Cruise in it
no it's based on a book about a troubled
aging horse trainer who needs retirement
money so kidnaps his boss's 11 year old
son and tries to get money from his
boss's wealthy Mexican ex-wife that's
gonna be a [ __ ] movie
I can't tell if it's a comedy if it's
action drama it's not a tumor it's not a
movie I'm tired of training these horses
so you're laughing you're all getting
there get in the truck with me if you
want to live why don't you leave me
alone now get in the truck because we
have to go and get money from you the
Mexican mother of yours John Gotti this
is yummy they're making about him with
John Travolta playing the mobster just
got a new cast member Kelly Preston is
going to be playing his wife of course a
stretch Travolta's real-life wife Kelly
Preston they're gonna have to pretend to
be heterosexual and help each other I
don't think either of them has the chops
quite frankly lindsay lohan of course
stars in the movie as well and
Travolta's daughter Ella blue is also
playing his daughter so they've got all
the bases covered in terms of sag
insurance for the next couple years for
his his family they got a new director
for that film by the way Barry Levinson
has decided to either direct that or
just kill himself and so he's gonna do
that instead I think he made the wrong
choice when your wife was pregnant did
she read that book what to Expect When
You're Expecting cover to cover
everybody reads that book if you got a
baby they tell you you got to read that
book what to Expect When You're
Expecting used to be that dr. Spock book
and them's now they give you this piece
live long and placenta difference dr.
Spock Oh
what's them to suit what to Expect When
You're Expecting is sort of it's a
self-help book it's an idea what's going
to happen to your body and know how it
changes over the time that you're
pregnant for that night right it's not
really a novel no but they're making a
movie about it Cameron Diaz is going to
star in the movie What to Expect When
You're Expecting I should have saved my
Hollywood do prediction I just realized
that this rumor I wasted it on the rock
that's so weird that'd be like taking
that [ __ ] when you're on a plane and
you pull that card out of your chair
they show you what to do yeah though
like let's make that a movie like it's
not really anything that lends itself to
a three-act structure we're just gonna
take the name let's see the warning on
matches close cover before striking
coming to a theater near you and then in
Hollywood that'd be like doesn't have to
be a match putting packing crates do not
eat the silica packets do not eat
starring Vin Diesel casting calls
Stephen Collins has been cast as the
villain in the Three Stooges movie yeah
he's the villain in the piece Stephen
Collins yeah remember Stephen Collins he
was the dad on 7-eleven
yeah he's the villain yeah Sean Hayes
has been announced as Larry Larry David
is gonna play a nun when did this movie
become an episode of The Love Boat all
of a sudden [ __ ] Bradley Cooper's been
offered the role of the devil in a film
version of the classic novel Paradise
Lost it's the story of the battle
between Michael and Lucifer the
Archangels and the story of Adam and Eve
and as we all know Bradley Cooper is one
of only two actors working today Ryan
Reynolds being the other
so he must be offering every time and
they look like there stays split from
the same DNA a little bit Rachel vice
has just been signed a star in the new
movie oz the great and powerful the
prequel to The Wizard of Oz James Franco
will star as a fast-talking snake oil
salesman who ends up in Oz and becomes
the wizard but cannot host The Wizard
Awards apparently that happened in Oz
that year Mila Kunis is one of the
witches Rachael vice plays one of the
witches and apparently Bradley Cooper
will play the other way yes Chris
Hemsworth we're talking about him as
Thor he is being offered the role of the
Huntsman in Snow White and the Huntsman
this is the retelling of the Snow White
story Kristen Stewart starring as Snow
White
a lot of support for that project
audiences will be rooting for the poison
apple I guess go Apple
well Charlize Theron's is playing the
evil witch do you between yeah that's
gonna skew the audience's anticipation
completely because you're gonna want her
to murder Snow White by the way and Bill
Murray has landed a role as Franklin
Delano Roosevelt in a drama called Hyde
Park on the Hudson
it'll be about President Franklin
Roosevelt's visit with King George the
sixth during the war King George the
sixth he's my favorite King dudes alone
he's like I'll give him [ __ ] whoa I
support it I love that guy the story
focuses on the visit and also
Roosevelt's alleged affair with his
distant cousin Daisy Daisy Roosevelt
yeah that's where the daisy chain came
from that's crazy
Roosevelt had an affair with a cousin
that's word on the street you ever see
his wife Eleanor yeah oh right
give me a sugar cube wait he was no
[ __ ] prize I saw him his legs did
work brother than that it was a
good-looking guy he used to ride her
around the rose garden
come on in and all one more lap anyone
old-timey with it Maxim released their
list of the hottest 100 women in the
world this week I'll just give you some
of the top 5 how about that number five
was Mila Kunis said 5 how about that
number 4 was Cameron Diaz
what the what is happening already man
that's it that's for sure
Katy Perry was third Olivia Munn was
second hold on one second there was a
lot of dissent from this corner what was
that boo all about you know or something
like that you work for you just can't
stand her
whoa I have to agree she is sort of
middle range I've never heard that
before I've never heard that's one of
mine is hot if you're at the Orange
Julius and she's the ones waiting on you
if you're at the food court and she's
giving you the wetzel pretzel you're
like oh I'd [ __ ] her she's Dairy Queen
huh yes but girl man that's so weird but
number two never since I got the guys
think she's Dairy Queen odd I'd [ __ ] her
in a Dairy Queen bathroom and it's
coming from a woman I'd give her the
Blizzard name Christine you're so
interesting
well christine has a point Olivia Wilde
is 15th on the list that we always do
you see this bring up a little bit a
while she thinks on how she's in Cowboys
and Aliens she's a truck she's introns a
stunner and Scarlett Johansson is 14th
January Jones from Mad Men is 12 she's
very attractive Jennifer Lawrence from
Winter's Bone is 10 Natalie Portman is 8
Olivia Munn is 2nd is what we're saying
yeah very um it's a DQ number one is
Rosie huntington-whiteley she's she is a
Victoria's Secret model who is the star
of Transformers Dark of the Moon the
upcoming transformers signature I don't
have a picture of her no but I'm
guessing Maxim has plenty of pictures of
her and that's why she's number one of
them it's arbitrary Ralph I don't know
that I necessarily agree with that list
well Christine will be happy to hear
that
Katy Perry's on the list we're talking
about her she grew up in a very
religious household Kent I just heard
that this week I didn't know that prior
she both of her parents were evangelical
ministers really she was not allowed to
use the phrase deviled eggs in her house
you know the delicacy the devil day when
my favorite foods it's the egg with the
yolk whipped with mustard and stuff and
then put back into the egg white it was
all [ __ ] day yeah she can't say
deviled eggs in her house they were
called angel eggs what they call devil
dogs angel dogs what they call the devil
angel
she said it backwards it was a D word we
weren't allowed to pronounce the D word
in her house they weren't allowed to buy
a Dirt Devil vacuum cleaner that's not a
joke that's for reals so so let's say
they were going to see a hockey game in
New Jersey new plane no no really
no no D word announced in their house at
any time that's why now she's [ __ ]
them doctor who look alike
and she kissed the girl and she liked
that
another hey this is why when I was a kid
we'd go to the the Catholic school
dances because these girls were just
waiting to get off the leash what'd she
catch you in gathered oh right some
born-again nutty [ __ ] but I thought
that was tragic tragic that she was
trapped in in a house like this that
trapped I mean you know so what you
can't say the word devil all right
good point
we're down for ya
just enough suppression a healthy amount
of suppression where she's like write
songs that are like pg-13 dirty what's
Justin Bieber doing in her house can't
do her boys man Simon Cowell is richer
than Elton John makjang and sting does
that seem right well that shows popular
ISM very popular he's got a bunch of
shows he's got the x-factor in the UK
which is you kid it's coming to the
States they released a list of the most
the biggest money makers in England one
in the music business he is worth six
hundred and eighteen million dollars
Elton John is only worth three hundred
twenty two million [ __ ] broke Mick
Jagger 313 million sting two hundred
ninety seven million Paul McCartney is
worth eighty excuse me eight hundred and
sixteen million dollars he is second on
the list above them all but Counting now
after that divorce even a bad yes Wow
and a news broke this week that he's
getting married again no what the [ __ ]
I imagine this time there'll be
something put in place where he doesn't
have to give up all that money why does
he have to get married he doesn't know
how to hire a prostitute but he can take
this broad as long as he doesn't have
that much longer to go he just hang out
with her well it's true what's he 68 67
64 he's not 60
I'm just saying look the love of your
life died already right yes
so you want you learned your lesson with
stumpy hoppy the gold digger took all
your money and so you learned that now
I'm just gonna keep the company of a
lady for as long as I have left we can
really have to get married
heaven answer me why I'm doing these
double you go we'll go back to his music
man what is it some people I want to
fill the world with silly love songs
down him he wants to fill women with his
dick you can't do that unless you're
married all right shows almost maybe
it's a Liverpudlian thing maybe it's
just like we have to get married and no
two tips that you do you got kid to the
boys we have to get married before we
have sex
that's why Ringo wouldn't [ __ ] me he's
right but I [ __ ] him but I'm dead wait
to the last one I'm John oh you want to
do you do George I'm tied to that was it
beside his MO did he like Connery you
got that's five and grotty you could do
all four Beatles yeah oh then go ahead
say uh let me see I mean something with
four things you know menudo c4 hard
day's night free okay what's my
grandfather he's a clean old man yeah
yes I've seen him he's very clean oh he
is clean but he looks fun of my nose I
don't know what I say but I've got brain
cancer
[Applause]
George didn't talk a lot in that movie
right well we're sorry and then we're
gonna see how big Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
where we get to Liam Neeson's massive
[ __ ] this is my favorite story of the
week and I don't want to ignore it
apparently now that they're all dead we
can talk about the fact that after the
horrible events of 9/11 Michael Jackson
Elizabeth Taylor and Marlon Brando all
got into a rental car and took a road
trip together this sounds like the
beginning of a dirty joke I know you've
said you're gonna quit making movies
after hit somebody but you got to make
one more movie Michael Jackson did two
shows in New York City at Madison Square
Garden on September 7th at September
10th
the next day 9/11 happened he had his
special guests there Marlon Brando 77
years old and Dame Elizabeth Taylor 69
years old there with him at the time
they were so panic-stricken by the
events of 9/11 as everyone in New York
was at the time and they couldn't get a
flight out
so they rented a car and the three of
them drove across country trying to get
back to Los Angeles which one drove man
like that's who who's behind my well we
make two turns can you do all the voices
can you do everyone in the car I want us
to pull over because they see
there's the Burger King over there man
that's what stopped and I'm really I'm
really in the mood for a chicken
sandwich I'm not kidding they say this
is story a right way you don't have an
Elizabeth Taylor no no one does just try
one do it do the duplicate don't you
know do him good Elizabeth hello I'm
Elizabeth I was grading Cleopatra I'm
not [ __ ] around when I say this comes
from Jackson's people that Brando kept
pissing the other two off by demanding
to stop and almost every Kentucky Fried
Chicken and Burger King restaurant he
saw along the way did you imagine man he
was like pull over I gotta take a piss
like use the cup I tried to use the cup
but I lost it in my phone I like I like
flame Burger King all right how big is
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] I don't know what's a
lie-down that's the question
[Music]
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is a tumbler you can
go to Liam Neeson's [ __ ] tumblr.com t
you and B I thought that was the
beginning of the routine like it's
Batman's tumbler something like I want
to keep I want to keep the you know the
jokes coming in so I want people to go
there and add they're always with it
these are some of our favorites from
from this week Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big every horse ride turns into a joust
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big you can
walk across it to get to Asgard
appropriate this week Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big he was able to join the
mile-high club without flying Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's ashamed of
how small its human is Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that after sex Liam
Neeson goes limp Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big when he gets crabs he doesn't use
a lotion to get rid of them he uses
artillery Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it has injured more people than
spider-man turn off the dark Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big donkeys in
Mexico pay to see him [ __ ] a woman this
is a good concept like a good Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's literally
impossible to make his Madame Tussaud
statue stands straight up right too long
yeah and poorly delivered yeah yeah Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's an anagram
for a sonic semen cloak
it is if you rearrange the letters and
leave me since coffee comes out Sonic
semen coke Oh Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big if placed carefully it can almost
hide Ralph's eyebrows wait a minute what
the [ __ ] some [ __ ] right there Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Curtis Mayfield
wrote a soundtrack for it that means but
I like this Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
when he was in the womb it looked like
his mom had a huge dick too assuming it
was hanging out good Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big you trying to comprehend it
put Stephen Hawking in the chair Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when Quint from
Jaws saw it he said I'll catch this [ __ ]
for you but it ain't gonna be easy it's
not like going down the pond chasing
blue gills and Tommy cuts this [ __ ]
swallow a whole little shaken little
tenderizing and down you go and we got
to do it quick that'll bring your beat
battling back your tourists but all your
business is on a paying basis but it's
not gonna be pleasant
I value my neck a lot more than 3,000
bucks chief I'll find him for three I'll
catch him and I'll kill him for ten but
you've got to make up your minds if you
want to stay alive and ante up you want
to play a cheap or be on the welfare all
winter I don't want no volunteers I
don't want no mates there's just too
many captains on this island $10
thousand dollars for me by myself for
that you get the head the shaft the
whole damn thing
the Hollywood babble-on this week I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman Nabal to
[ __ ] off everybody good night
[Music]